you know this whole question of loyalty
that Trump always brings up well
DeSantis wasn't loyal to me loyalty
loyalty loyalty I don't know how loyal
Tucker was to Fox keep in mind
he's been on CNN before Crossfire with
Alan Combs or whatever his name was
uh he's been on MSNBC Tucker's not a
Roger Ailes groomed product of fox he's
been around the block talented no doubt
been all over Washington I don't know
how much loyalty Tucker has
to Fox and then if you go down the the
rabbit hole of who's really been the the
top dogs at Fox
I feel like Fox believes their brand is
bigger than one particular person just a
handful of years ago it was all about
Megan Kelly yeah then she took her ball
and left to uh took her talents to NBC I
believe her ABC she's no longer there
anymore she's building her own podcast
she's crushing it